also wir stehen ja gerade in dem
flugzeug hangar der ehemalige britischen
streitkräfte die vor jahren den kreis
gütersloh verlassen haben der festigen
kann man eben einmal einmal schalten und
einmal einmal rüber schwingen wie es
hier so aussieht momentan wird das ganze
noch aufgebaut um halb oder 20 nach 6
uhr das ganze hier funktionieren und
starten
und ich habe hier einen gesprächspartner
und zwar den pressesprecher des
kreisfeuerwehrverbandes in gütersloh
statt erklären sie mir was ist das heute
abend für eine förderaktion und wie
haben sie es geschafft das wirklich so
kurzfristig aus dem boden zu stampfen
ja die aktion ist hier dass die testung
des der bevölkerung des kreises
gütersloh durchgeführt werden jetzt ab
dem jetzigen augenblick an sechs
standorten hier an dem standort
flughafen gütersloh marienfelder straße
und gleich in zusammenarbeit mit allen
ehrenamtlichen kräften ja hier
hilfsorganisationen der bundeswehr hier
vor ort wie funktioniert das wenn wir
uns mal umdrehen zeigen sie uns das mal
hier werden gleich pkws der bürger wird
gleich hier rein fahren in die halle
der bürger wird dann an eine station
kommen wo test team steht dort wird sein
so werden seine daten aufgenommen
dort werden dann anschließend die
testung durchgeführt und dann fährt der
bürger wieder aus dem drive-in hier so
kann man es wirklich nennen an 13
stellen waren die bürger hier mit ihren
autos rein
sie steigen nicht aus sie haben keinen
kontakt zu anderen bürgern und von
anschließend wieder raus und verlassen
das gelände sagen sie noch ein bisschen
was wer ist ja alles unterwegs und wie
schwer war das mit der logistik das
wirklich jetzt auf den punkt gegen zu
bekommen die anordnung dass das ganze
heute stattfindet es gestern abend
gekommen über das land nordrhein
westfalen
gestern abend wurde schon die
materialien alarm mäßig aus denen aus
die aus dem ausland nrw hier zu uns
gebracht logistisch sind hier alle
einheiten die es gibt in nordrhein
westfalen und auch in der bundesrepublik
zu nennen da will ich kein vergessen
bundeswehr thw feuerwehr alle einfach
alle arbeiten hier zusammen alles greift
zusammen alles funktioniert sehr gut und
alle sind sehr motiviert und das ist
sehr sehr positiv an dieser stelle
das möchte ich auch im namen des kreises
gütersloh hier weiter geben also nee du
hörst also hier würde wirklich richtig
was geschaffen in wirklich kürzester
zeit
und ist das zum beispiel das testzentrum
in gütersloh maximal 1000 leute pro tag
testen kann und deshalb sind weitere
tests zentren ja quasi über nacht aus
dem boden gestampft worden und jetzt
hier diese diese lagerhalle diesen alten
hubschrauber hunger in kürzester zeit um
zu funktionieren
da muss man den hilfskräften und der
bundeswehr wirklich ein riesenkompliment
machen die wollen halt alles dafür tun
dass die leute möglichst zügig durch
getestet werden weil ja dieser negative
test die möglichkeit bietet die kreise
zu verlassen und wir warten jetzt sehr
gespannt bis die ersten autos kommen die
bundeswehrsoldaten werden jetzt gerade
noch eingewiesen damit ja auch alles
funktioniert natürlich wird das jetzt
nicht bei den ersten fünf autos alles
locker flockig laufen sondern das muss
sich auch alles so ein bisschen ein
gerufen
aber die truppe ist ja wirklich stark
motiviert genauso wie die hilfskräfte
das bis wirklich bis zur dunkelheit
durchzuziehen und nicht zu warten und
nicht auf die uhr zu gucken sondern hier
zu testen bis der letzte wirklich
getestet wurde
michael engelberg du wirst uns dann auf
dem laufenden halten dankeschön